-Welcome back to the show,
buddy.
I appreciate you being here.
-Thanks for having me back.
It's so nice to see you
and hug you.
-And hug you, yeah. And slow
dance with you. It felt great.
-Yeah, that's really
the reason I came.
I felt like I should just go.
-Yeah, every time.
Who better to have on Broadway
Week than Ben Platt?
Thank you for being here.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Broadway reopened last night.
-Yes.
-You already saw a show.
-I went to the reopening
of "Wicked."
-No way!
-Yes.
-Good for you.
-Yeah, "Wicked"!
-How was it?
-It was like a crazy exp--
I feel like I'm still
sort of vibrating from it
'cause it was like
a rock concert.
Like, every other line got
a standing ovation and a scream.
It took like an hour
to get to the first song.
[ Laughter ]
It was incredible.
Like, when she flies at the end
of the first act,
everybody just kind of was,
"Oh, we're all going to stand.
Okay," and everybody
just kind of stood
and watched it from standing,
but it was a dream come true.
And I got to be with
my boyfriend, Noah,
who came with me,
and we love "Wicked" together,
so it's great.
-Come on. Congrats.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's great.
Last time you were on Broadway,
you won a Tony, my man.
Not bad.
-Yeah, I did. Thanks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you remember the feeling
after, like,
Tina Fey gave you the Tony?
Do you remember exactly
what happened in your mind?
-Yeah, it was like, "Okay.
Hello, Tina Fey. Hello, Tony."
And then yelled my speech
as fast as I could.
And they tried to play me off,
but I made it to the end.
And then, I walked off stage,
and Lin-Manuel was just --
Lin-Manuel Miranda
was just standing there,
waiting to go
and present the next award.
And so I just kind of
instinctively kind of just went
into his arms and he sort of
just hugged me.
[ Laughter ]
And then, there was
a photographer backstage
who immediately was like,
"Let me just snap a pic."
And I, like, turn and took
the picture with him.
And I -- it's online somewhere,
but it's --
I look like I just smoked
a ton of crack.
It's just like --
-Yeah, I know.
It's not even online. I have it.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah.
-There you are, there. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You're really psyched.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're really -- You're really
into it. Wow.
You're really excited
about that.
-It was really intense.
So that's -- Yeah.
That really sums it up.
-We had Beanie Feldstein
on the show last week, who I
know you've known for a --
[ Audience cheers ]
Yeah, we love her.
And she's great in the new
"Impeachment."
-Amazing.
Her performance is incredible.
You and her were prom dates.
-We were prom dates. Yes.
-I did not know who you --
I saw it on your wall,
I think, last time you did
our show from home.
And I saw it in your house. I
was like, "Wait, what is that?"
-Yeah, we were best friends
in high school,
and we were prom dates, and my
favorite part about that now
is that when I asked her
to prom, I sent her flowers,
and I wrote a little card
that said --
Beanie loves "Funny Girl,"
which for those who don't know,
she's going to star
in "Funny Girl" on Broadway
this year.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Which is wild.
-Yeah.
-And I always knew she loved
"Funny Girl," so it said like,
"Don't rain on my parade.
Please come to prom with me."
-No way.
[ Audience aws ]
-And now she's Fanny Brice.
Here's the picture.
Here's your prom photo.
-Uh-huh.
-Look at this.
-There's prom dates right there.
That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes. We're doing the --
-Did you both always --
-Eva Peron arms.
-Did you always both have dreams
of being on Broadway?
-Yes, absolutely. We were
big theater nerds together.
We starred in all the musicals
together in high school.
And it was always our dream.
Actually, for my 16th birthday,
she gave me cuff links.
And she gave me a little note
that I have saved that said,
"Wear these when you win
your first Tony," and I did.
[ Audience aws ]
And I wore them at Radio City.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Dude, that is the best!
I love that story!
That's so cool, man.
-Thanks.
-You released your new album,
"Reverie."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
People love it,
and you're going on tour.
This poster is
all over New York City.
I don't know if you have seen it
on the side of the Garden.
It is gigantic.
A giant Ben Platt.
-Just my armpit.
[ Laughter ]
-It's just the armpit.
That's it.
The rest is covered over.
But this is big, man.
-It's cool. It's really cool.
-You're playing big arenas.
-Yeah.
I mean, I've never played
my original music
in spaces this big.
The biggest place I think
I've ever played is
when I was nine years old,
I did the Hollywood Bowl
because I was in "The Music Man"
there, the musical.
I played the little kid,
Winthrop, in it.
And so I'm playing that again
on the tour.
So it's sort of like
a little full circle
back to the Bowl
as myself little moment.
-I thought you were playing
Winthrop.
-Yeah, yeah, no, I'm actually
just touring --
[ Laughter ]
-You're doing "Music Man"?
-Just the Winthrop material
from "Music Man."
[ Laughter ]
-That's the tour?
But this is major, dude.
-Thanks.
-I love this move, by the way.
Were you on a trampoline here?
-Just straight from the ground.
-Straight-from-the-ground jump.
-On my own natural high.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Just trying to give
like a Springsteen,
kind of Peter Gabriel,
a little Phil Collins vibe.
-Yeah, I got that vibe.
Have you been watching
any shows,
getting inspiration
for your tour?
-Well, I -- my dream for the
tour is to combine, like,
all my favorite pop shows I've
seen, like Beyoncé and Ariana.
Like the shows
that are big spectacles
and got everybody up moving
and a lot of tempo.
And then also my other favorite
show I ever saw at the Garden
was Barbra Streisand, of course.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes, Barbra!
[ Laughter ]
And she makes the whole giant
stadium feel like
you're all in her living room.
-Yeah, she does.
-It's just so intimate and,
like, she's telling so much
honest stories and making you
laugh and so off-the-cuff.
So I'd love to find,
like, a beautiful,
little middle ground, where we
can, like, party and dance
but also, like, I can tell
my secrets and stuff.
And it'll be fun.
-Buddy, congrats on this tour
and the album.
-Thanks.
-I want to talk about
"Dear Evan Hansen."
This is in theaters next Friday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Next Friday. It's happening.
-It's happening, finally. Yes.
-When you did the play,
you don't think that
it's going to be a movie.
You just hope the play is good.
-Exactly, yeah. It's so rare
that a musical
gets the privilege
of becoming a film
and even rarer
that somebody is allowed
to transfer the performance
onto film.
So I never assumed that this
would happen and -- and I --
you know, I dreamt about it when
the show started getting big
and people started loving it,
but I did not --
especially once the pandemic
started, I was like,
"Well, now this is
never going to happen."
But Universal and
the director and the writers,
everybody was really focused on
getting this story done
'cause they thought it was
really important for right now.
It's all about, you know,
everyone's universal experience
of isolation and loneliness and
the need for human connection.
And I feel like, unfortunately
right now, that's, like,
even more important than it was
when the show came out.
So I'm just grateful that
it came together
and they let me do it.
-I got to see you on Broadway.
I was lucky.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's great.
I got to see you perform.
I was lucky enough to see you
on Broadway, and man, oh man,
I was like, "Dude, just stop,"
after the second song.
I go, "This guy's unbelievable,
man.
Just stop. We're good.
Just stop, man."
[ Laughter ]
I heard that when you were
shooting the movie,
they yelled "cut" after a scene,
and then they had to stop
because all the crew
were crying.
People had to, like -- The boom
guy had to wipe his tears.
It was like, "Alright,
everyone, regroup.
We got to do another take."
-Yeah, it was
a very emotional setting.
I mean, this is my director
Stephen Chbosky's story, really,
but I'll steal it, which is
that, on the second day,
I was doing one of the songs.
It's called, "Words Fail."
It's kind of one of the darker,
kind of more difficult,
emotional songs.
And the first take
I performed it,
and it was very early on
in the shoot,
so a lot of the crew in Atlanta
didn't know
what they were in for.
So I sang the song,
and then there was a lot of
silence after the cut.
And no one really said anything,
and then an unidentified
crew member who we love
but we don't know who it was,
came over the walkie
and just went,
"Well, this is going to
be a good movie."
[ Laughter ]
-That's it. That's what you
need. That's a good omen.
The walkie says so.
You got to believe it.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Ben Platt
in "Dear Evan Hansen."
Take a look at this.
♪ -Even when the dark
comes crashing through ♪
♪ When you need a friend
to carry you ♪
♪ And when you're broken
on the ground ♪
♪ You will be found ♪
♪ So let the sun come
streaming in ♪
♪ 'Cause you'll reach up
and you'll rise again ♪
♪ Lift your head
and look around ♪
♪ You will be fooooound ♪
♪ You will be foooooound ♪
♪ You will be foooooooound ♪
♪ You will be found ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. Come on, now.
You got it. Ben Platt!
"Dear Evan Hansen" is in
theaters September 24th.